se concluyó este jueves en milán la
conferencia internacional de los jóvenes
por el clima por klein con un llamado a
la comunidad internacional para que se
adopten acciones concretas reales en la
lucha contra el cambio climático cerca
de 400 jóvenes de 197 países
participaron a este evento entre ellos
la activista sueca greta thunberg quien
ha criticó la inacción desde el mundo de
la política y reclamó reformas radicales
para luchar contra el calentamiento
global también se hizo un llamado para
que se limite el uso de energía fósil se
promueva la educación climática en las
escuelas y se dé asistencia a las
poblaciones vulnerables más afectadas
por los efectos del calentamiento global
mensajes que se espera sean escuchados
por los líderes del mundo en la
conferencia de la onu sobre el cambio
climático la cob 26 que se llevará a
cabo en glasgow el próximo mes de
noviembre